j'ai pris des bonnes résolutions pour
2003 bon je pêchais pas encore pensé en
réponse 2002 et après on va y penser
interview bonnes résolutions
alors en 2003 clotilde courau qu'est ce
que vous avez décidé de plus faire
je sais pas de plus faire chambrer
chanter ouais voulait plus chanter oui
et plus a encore afin jeunes à kita
c'est bien qu'est ce que vous avez
décidé de ne plus faire en 2003 plus de
tous de ne plus faire du tout
j'ai du mal lorsque tu as bien non si
cette gamme on a fait pas dans sérieuse
je serai pas avec les mains c'est que je
sais plus faire
donnez moi des exemples
s'il vous plaît plus folles les choux
pas
arrêté devant l'école arrêté de boire de
l'alcool elle boit pas non mais c'est
tout cela prouverait que je sais pas là
la préoccupation majeure c'est vrai que
sais je suis un peu venu dans cette
émission je suis un peu je suis très
heureuse de parler des films de
guillaume et du film de jon important
mais
je pense qu'on forme de violence un
dance est un peu et avant les lourds non
non c'est pas du tout ça c'est juste que
je suis un peu concerné par ce qui se
passe en côte d'ivoire personnellement
et que c'est difficile d'être là pour
moi parce que
il y à il ya un pays qui est dans une
drôle de situation
j'y ai carrément coupée en deux non mais
c'est vrai un problème en ce moment la
guerre maintenant j'ai vu qu'ils avaient
des rebelles encore ailleurs à l'ouest
voilà et que j'ai mon papa qui est là
bas et qui ne veut pas comme un homme
qui est sur un front et qui ne voudrait
pas se cacher sous terre ne veux pas
revenir de rabot
je suis en pleine d'émotion mais
pourquoi il veut parvenir non sérieux
sait que c'est dangereux quand même non
parce que je crois qu'il est tombé
follement amoureux de ces pays et que
c'est sa vie tout simplement ces deux
univers il est ingénieur conseil
depuis longtemps qu'il y ait
donc les questions en 2003 6 ce que je
voudrais faire ci est ce que je voudrais
faire ça pour l'instant sera
effectivement en 2003 que ça se passe
mieux pour tout le monde et qu'on
n'arrive pas tout ça est dans le droit
dans le mur et que tant qu'il ya de
l'appétit ya de la vie et qu'on en
profite au maximum avec générosité
simplicité voilà tout simplement
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le il
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu